se tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
momento io sono felice ed oggi siamo su
pesa del ore gressan che fa rima con
cacao meravigliao pensatelo è un
videogame che avevo giocato un sacco di
tempo fa la demo proprio giocato la demo
adesso è uscito il gioco completo si
chiama pesate loro regressivo l'altro è
un gioco portoghese quindi già madre
teresa o si potrà capire una marca di
grissini salve ci sono dei condotti ci
sono delle quelli sono dei computer di
nuova generazione che giochi a skyrim
tanti fps o un uomo con la barba questo
sì che è un protagonista ma io stavo
dentro una navicella spaziale prima
dov'è finita domanda ragazzi sto gioco
qua si gioca anche o si guardano scenari
di uno che sbocca nel lavandino e basta
posso giocare ciao sono fa vj facci
gameplay
noi guardiamo ragazzi guardiamo una
trama profonda
un po come si guarda mi hai fatto
perdere mezz'ora della mia vita e non ho
capito un cazzo quindi ottimo inizio
ovviamente casa mia a questo già vino
quindi ovvio e sipro posso entrare io sì
giorno salve è no non è una porta devi
stare bene la porta deve stare chiusa
non è un problema se pare viva momento
si importante della sua vita
no grazie a sporche mese chiusa la porta
a casa che sta resto e del bagno e se il
bagno poi doppi char poi those bloccarne
il secchio è la madonna alle
bottigliette il cappello di ash dei
pokémon posso uscire senza che mi stupri
qualcuno che bella è passata la mia
ragazza con le mestruazioni
adesso si spiega chi è che rischiava la
porta prima giustamente anche posto di
merda vi inizio a casa tua città arriva
dalla fibra no perché non sembra
ecco qua è passata la mia ragazza
ragazzi l'obiettivo di questo gioco e
trovare la mia ragazza giustamente
vietato fumare no guarda è vietato
fumare ma non è vietato sporcare di
sangue pavimento quello va bene signor
dracula non vorrei disturbarla però devo
aprire questa tom heiner guardi che non
può fumare signor dracula glielo dico
quest'uomo si è svegliato che sarà in
cosa è successo qualcuno mi ha colpito
ma non ho capito chi posso recuperare
vita comunque sarò va a figo quindi con
l'acqua si recupera vita fantastico bene
grazie di avermelo detto giorno mi
sembra strano che ci sia una persona è
vivo guardi che non si può fumare lei
che c'è questa faccia bella di capire
una cosa senti guardavia questa
scrivania posso prendere questa scia è
dartela sul muso semis punti davanti
emigri di in faccia ti uccido a silvio
gres prefetto salvarle perfetto salvato
e ora le batterie se ci avessi una
torcia sarebbe fantastico però non ce lo
frate china torcia madonna si però
sembra che ti è morta la zia c'è un po
di allegria e frate cioè la testa
carciofo però sei figo pattato stai
perdendo sangue manco a sto parlando io
qua
ma che cazzo gli chiedi se può aiutarti
che sembra morto vivente è vero guarda
una di quelle mi ha tentato di azan armi
la faccia devo preparare un elisir per
curarti le ferite ma che per chi mi hai
preso per un farmacista allora la
bottiglia d'acqua ce l'ho mi manca la
pianta ramo dermica senti frate fi
incasso
come ma cerca la tuta pianta perché non
è che ci voglia di calais para così è
figo mica posso scavalcare seriamente ma
che sarebbe stato troppo bello che
banche sono arrivato dall altra parte ma
mi sa che non doveva andare così sono
arrivato dall altra parte così a caso
vabbè 6 st romane è un pezzo di carta
guarda zio grazie ma noi in questo
momento non m'interessa pro grazie mille
che avevavo [ __ ] sentii [ __ ] lo dice
qualcun altro spiega ogni problema del
una porta permesso a pigna pensavo fosse
un televisore che lampeggiava generatore
di energia sky lux vaffan
ma chi cazzo sei 66 e eva prima che me
sfruttato di godzilla né spuntato ma chi
come che entra l'altro era sempre più
bello del mio amico di prima cioè mi ha
fatto più paura lui in realtà che questo
tizio andiamo avanti
trovo è la pianta visto che mi hai preso
corner balista e sono sceso sono scemo
ma io sono scemo ma io sono idiota ma
aveva una torcia da un'ora e mezza e non
l'avevo manco vima genio bravo favi
bravo
mi chiamo trovato subito che è che figo
che adesso vedo le cose escono era
meglio sono vedere un cazzo devo fare
una piantina più l'acqua quindi devo
combinarla per forza si con la piantina
ecco la bottiglia di piscio la si prende
la si dà all'uomo del pesce è giusto chi
sta ultrà per grease sarebbe fiero di te
fratello comunque sia non è un problema
che fa dove vuoi andare ma no frate è
quella che ci sono già andato di là
zio ascoltano serio sono serio se
scavalchino va beh tu non sei capace ma
io ce la faccio mi sa che era proprio un
bug del gioco
avrei dovuto scavalcare per niente
grazie molto gentile e neanche tu questo
non c'ha voglia di vivere bravo frate fa
il cazzo che vuoi il proprio dove andare
di qua capire gold e agro tossico
l'italiano ragazzi sarebbe pollo in agro
di coe una cosa che si mangia in realtà
salve air a tizi prima quindi che
avvisano che c'è un pizzo che ti vuole
stuprare nella noceto dicono alla la tv
è laggiù se io non fosse frego dentro si
possono mettere no vabbè ma che cazzo di
sfiga ma visto ma visto [ __ ] vabbè
ascolta zio scorta mi si è chiuso non
salutare le maniglie gesù ti ringrazio
non so come sia possibile ragazzi ma il
tipo è rimasto chiuso dentro sul serio
vai fantastico e ogni qua quanto quanto
è grosso sto posto fate mica è un
cimitero e uno stadio fanno anche nei
sogni è indecente posso aprire una bara
sei serio a pisa è l'altro pezzo di
carta che hanno trovato un altro primato
con poi ricomporli perché sono a pezzi
come come è possibile
hamas ha mai un altro che quote grosso
questo dio non fermi fa mentre per
entrare per l'amor di dio protegga sua
mente senti zio proteggimi prima il culo
chiaramente perché in questo momento non
mi sento in grado di proteggere tutto
cazzo è porca [ __ ] chiude su cape
stato fosse passato ma non era passato
per niente io ringrazio veramente gesù
che si quando sanno dalle maniglie
perché sono storia e roero morto o
[ __ ] magma di brutto proprio c'è tra
l'altro basta dio mio accordi costa un
piccione morto
ah no è un testo perfetto vai vai vai
volta si può uscire se magari go to the
cave find che esce mancava devo trovare
la chiave per aprire il cancello e poi
posso uscire
l'ascensore ma sensore l'ascensore nelle
di un cimitero magath che cimitero ea
non funziona perché manca il generatore
per te pareva che c'è ma in gara solo
quello questura validi e 30 la caverna
quindi e qui sotto perché c'è un
ascensore che porta nelle caverne ma che
cazzo di gioco era ecco il cavo ecco
generato al volo già trovato minchia
l'elettricista ragazzi sono riuscito a
trovare il generatore in un nanosecondo
posso andare al generatore che lo devo
accendere che devo farmi view sta ci
mancava che non c'era chiellini in
difesa pure qua un sacco a pelo ma
perché c'è qualcuno che dorme qui così
ho trovato la batteria del generatore
sono già posto trova un gallone di
gasolina è una batteria e connetti le a
batteria al gallone della gasolina ok
allora la batteria già ce l'ho mi manca
la gasolina per favore las divinas
venite a darmene amano tanto fatemi se
non è questa la gasolina no lo trovai
poco una tanica fantastico e fatemi
uscire prima che cos'è e la mappa del
veramente c'è un armadietto con
lucchetto
ma per chi mi hai preso che uno che
scassina i lucchetti ci ho provato è
quando andavo in piscina con gli
armadietti a scassinare i lucchetti però
non ha funzionato poi est a chi e
generatore e stuckey e selena gomez non
desta selena gomez è scritto non c'è
scritto che mappa schifo tutti i punti
dove puoi andare a rompere le palle
tutti ma visto non ho mai visto non mi
ha visto ma vi sto [ __ ] ma visto
non ho mai e non aveva visto si stava
fermo non mi vedevo affanculo sapevo io
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye porca eva che c'era un tizio prima
prova che non c'è più
vi seguo ancora questo generatore
comunque put item battere imposition
perfetto ci siamo ragazzi anche questo
si apre un altro pezzo ma il codice
lucchetto sta roba
io trovo cose a caso e la tara salve e
io entro 4 3 non si faccia domande se
vuole entrare anche lei nel privè deve
avere il passo perché sennò non entra ho
capito dove trovare i costi ferire per
il lucchetto regate lo dice dove sono
minchia ecco perché per suonare è
impossibile uno stava qui l'altro che ho
preso dove stavate questo e quindi mi
mancano 6 3 al mio tre skin chiamo come
se fosse usain bolt ci siete 13 mai mai
mai mai mai veloce veloce il segue anche
gesù abbiamo seminato il tizio dopo un
anno e mezzo quindi qua qua ce n'è uno
sulla terza tomba subito quindi 123
eccole questo qua al tratto ci si
conoscono proprio c'è si vede
ok ho già preso non ho trovato trovato
perfetto 6 comodo là dentro fate bar non
lo zio però nel dubbio ti lascio
volentieri là dentro perché a dirti la
verità mi storia abbastanza sul culo te
lo dico 4 21 dopo finito eccolo ma dato
il prezzo completo credo che sia una
moltiplicazione 4x5 per 8 x 21 x 15 cioè
che devo mettere piante quindi erba
lista doveva anche il matematico tra
tutte proprio matematica che mi sta in
culo dovrete scegliere porca eva fatemi
andare prima a lucchetto che manco se ci
arrivò come me scappano prima lo sapevo
l'ho detto io è via via via via via ecco
che cazzo ci fai tu qui su ca sono
arrivato sia arrivato è arrivato star in
atto su arrivato è arrivato
ok ok non mi arriva mi prende così vero
non posso neanche aprire l'inventario
per guardare la moltiplicazione devo
ricordarmi i numeri allora 5x4 fatto in
piana calcolatrice gesù allora professor
professore di matematica tu che guardi i
miei video mi da almeno sei 50.400
50.400 è uscito è giusto andiamo a tutti
a sbocciare belvedere robe è sbagliato e
profumi di a 5 per l'impegno che codice
strano san manuel e questo secondi si o
ci metto un attimino sai calmo è ecco la
tanica ho trovata ok ok allora una due
tre torri forest corrie è rimasto lì e
lo sai non sai giocare non sei giocare
perché la gente qui c'è pausa la caga di
vedermi cia polacca perché sanno che io
li chiudo lì dentro che mi metto in
punizione proprio vabbè ce l'ho fatta
ragazzi e ho finito tutto generator un
grandissimo
15 secondi ma sei scemo come 15 minuti
minchia coscienza anch'io sono scemo al
15 minuti ci arrivo ci riprendono anche
un tè coi miei amici in 15 minuti
minchiate l'ho fatto ragazzi non ci
posso credere poi anche l'ardore che
soli spero che ai video vi sia piaciuto
con colloqui l'episodio bene 3 suspense
visto che non sapete cosa c'è di sotto
dell scopriremo insieme nel prossimo
episodio ragazzi però ha concluso che il
video spero che vi sia piaciuto e cosa
sei tu sei video è piaciuta lasciato un
commento
non mi piace anche la pagina di facebook
e come gli ottant'anni e schizzi anni si
sono iscritti ci picchiavano prossimo
vivo della ragazza